[Música]
i
y
a la vida es una lucha la vida no es
fácil pero depende de ti si te quieres
hacer víctima o quieres hacerte un
guerrero y resiliente en esta vida desde
pequeña me me han molestado las
injusticias siendo de la ciudad de
mexico una ciudad de millones de
habitantes multicultural y multirracial
clasista con discriminación pues me ha
tocado luchar desde la ciudad de mexico
mi pareja trabajaba en el transporte
público donde por tres ocasiones él
sufrió secuestros express un día
estábamos a punto de cumplir nuestro
aniversario de estar juntos y me dijo
vamos a salir y después de haber
disfrutado todo ese día al día siguiente
nos regresamos a casa él fue cuando me
dio la noticia que le iba a venir a eeuu
con su tío rafael
para mí fue una noticia fuerte ya que
cuando tú amas a tu pareja pues sientes
que se te va la mitad de ti la gente no
entiende muchas veces lo difícil que es
que es venir y dejar tu vida allá pero
tome valor y dije bueno tengo que llegar
con mi hija pensando en todas las
circunstancias que íbamos a atravesar
en el primer intento de cruzar las
personas que nos recogieron era una
pareja nos explicaron cómo íbamos a
cruzar y mi hija iba a pasar con ellos
como hija de ellos yo iba a cruzar por
la línea ellos me iban a esperar del
otro lado pero desafortunadamente cuando
llegamos al check-in que está en las
cruces nuevo méxico ahí nos detuvieron
nos pidieron documentación el papel que
yo traía como supuestamente permiso para
venir era falso no servía y a mí me
bajaron el ver a mi hija alejarse en el
carro con estas personas que yo no
conocía era para mí un dolor tan grande
pensar que si mi hija iba a llegar con
su papá o no iba a llegar con su papá yo
estuve detenida todo el día fui de
vuelta a méxico donde en ese tiempo
estaba la muerte de mujeres en ciudad
juárez pasé por una situación muy
difícil ahí ya que unos hombres trataron
de robarme lo que traía yo pude sacarme
y corrí corrí corrí hasta que alguien me
salvó y me llevó a un lugar seguro
lo primero que hice cuando pude regresar
a la casa donde me estaba quedando fue
pedir el teléfono y preguntar si mi hija
había llegado bien cuando escuché que ya
estaba aquí sentí que mi corazón regreso
a mí pero también era pensar que para mí
ya era más difícil mi hija ahora estaba
acá yo seguía en méjico y ya no podía
regresar atrás porque ahora tenía que
cruzar o tenía que cruzar ay fue fue mi
primera experiencia de dolor porque yo
nunca me había separado de mi hija de
ahí tomé otra vez valor 15 días después
intenté nuevamente regresar y pude
cruzar y llegué exactamente un 24 de
diciembre del año 97
yo me imaginaba llegar a algo diferente
pero llegamos a la casa del tío donde me
tocó dormir en el piso de la sala de la
casa con solo una cobija
ese es el sueño americano del que la
gente muchas veces habla tener que
llegar a sufrir experiencias pues no muy
buenas pero no me rendí y de ahí comencé
a buscar dónde ir a vivir solos llegamos
a la casa de unas personas que nos
rentaron un cuarto donde solo teníamos
nuestra ropa no teníamos absolutamente
nada solo nuestra ropa y era pensar
comenzar de nuevo de cero pero siempre
he tenido el carácter fuerte ya que mis
padres me crearon muy fuerte busqué
trabajo a conseguir trabajo como janitor
porque aunque nosotros tenemos estudios
en nuestro país nos toca venir a
trabajar de lo que sea en este país ya
como janitor empecé a ver y experimentar
las injusticias de trabajo que había en
los lugares la sobrecarga de trabajo las
faltas de salarios violaciones a los
derechos laborales y teníamos un
contrato laboral entre compañía y entre
empleadores y el sindicato lo empecé a
estudiar completamente para ver qué eran
mis derechos cuando lo termine de leer
pude empezar a educar a mis
de que eran sus derechos cómo se podían
defender basado en su contrato
de esa manera empecé a organizar y
después tenía cinco edificios
organizados
la gente me buscaba para que yo les
resolviera sus problemas se pasaban
información unos a otros y pues
prácticamente ahí comenzó mi activismo
en eeuu a sólo cinco meses de estar aquí
el mismo sindicato si hay un loco one of
fire que era el que nos representaba
como trabajadores recibo una noticia que
me querían contratar para trabajar
directamente con ellos para mí era guau
es uno de los sindicatos más grandes
importantes del país es venir
de trabajadora de limpieza a ser
organizadora los retos que sentía que
venían conmigo ya que yo expliqué que yo
no tenía el idioma que recién había yo
he llegado aquí y dije qué voy a hacer y
me explicaron lo que ya estás haciendo
organizar a tu comunidad tu comunidad
consciente y bueno decidí aceptar ese
reto donde para mí era muy importante
saber que mi trabajo era para los
trabajadores no para el sindicato no
para los empleadores sino para la gente
que pagaba sus cuotas y que iban a
continuar pagando mi salario un día
saliendo de mi segundo trabajo porque en
ese tiempo tenía dos trabajos ya que
parecía que el papá de mis hijos estaba
enfermando nuevamente yo era la cabeza
de la familia saliendo de mi segundo
trabajo 14 de febrero de 2009 10 18 de
la noche una patrulla me enciende las
luces al carro que traía tenía los
stickers vencidos porque yo tenía que
poner comida en la mesa de mi casa o
comprar los stickers y para mí era más
importante poner comida en la mesa de mi
casa para ese tiempo ya tenía luna que
solo tenía cuatro años y a roberto que
solo tenía dos años cuando el oficial me
para primero ver mi aspecto físico y me
pregunta estás legal o ilegal en este
país le dije perdón no entiendo tu
pregunta por qué me estás deteniendo me
repitió que si estás legal o ilegal en
este país
yo dije voy a voy a guardar mi derecho
de mantenerme callada ya que conozco mis
derechos y eso lo enfureció me pidió mis
documentos al no tener licencia de
conducir entregué como identificación mi
matrícula consular pero mi instinto de
madre me dijo que no iba a regresar a
casa
pude poner mi teléfono en speaker le
hablé a mi pareja y le dije me detuvo
una patrulla probablemente no regreso a
casa por favor cuida mucho a mis hijos
y yo voy a hacer todo para regresar si
me detienen desafortunadamente me
detuvieron pero afortunadamente conocía
mis derechos perdía muy fuerte desde
dentro
estuve 34 días detenida donde solo podía
ver a mis hijos a lo lejos cuando ellos
me mandaban besos y me decían a lo lejos
ahí lo vio mami era un dolor tan fuerte
que me vieran encadenada de pies y manos
como una criminal por solo no tener una
licencia de conducir y mis stickers
vencidos eso me llenaba más de rabia de
indignación y yo decía yo voy a salir de
aquí pude salir después de 34 días
pagando una fianza de 4 mil dólares y
ahí viendo todas las violaciones de
derechos humanos en los centros de
detención como se maltrata a la gente la
falta de atención médica
todo lo que sucede dentro de estos
lugares horribles que son privados y que
aún así violan los derechos humanos
cuando yo salí decidí que iba a empezar
el movimiento de derechos de inmigrantes
en colorado porque nadie hablaba de
inmigración
organice por dos años primero educando a
la comunidad sobre el tema sobre todo lo
que sucedía sobre cómo estas
corporaciones lucraban de nosotros como
seres humanos que tenían ganancias
millonarias y de ahí seguí mi lucha
seguí mi lucha hasta 2011 que la juez en
mi corte final dijo que yo tenía que
irme porque mis hijos eran pequeños que
no iban a sufrir sufrimiento extremo y
que se podían adaptar a cualquier lugar
otra vez me llene de indignación y
decidí que iba a apelar la decisión
tenía mi apelación pendiente con solo un
año cuando recibo una llamada de mi
hermana en mexico y me dijo mi mamá está
en el hospital tiene cáncer terminal y
solo le dan tres días de vida tú decides
qué hacer
para mí era muy difícil pensar qué
tenía que seguir mi lucha y que si yo
iba mi caso se iba a complicar ya tenía
sur y que sólo tenía un año tres meses
pero también iba a ser la última vez que
iba a ver a mi madre y mi corazón
decidió que yo tenía que ir
me fui fue una decisión desgarrante ya
que estaba dejando mi vida entera aquí
que son mis hijos pero es lo que el
sistema nos hace hacer
estuve allá pude ver a mi madre mi madre
falleció pasé siete largos meses en
mexico sufriendo discriminación en mi
propio país porque no encontraba trabajo
basado en mi edad después de siete meses
experimentamos lo que es estar separados
y decidí regresar como la primera vez
fue muy difícil otra vez dejar a mi
padre pensar que iba a durar 15 años más
para volverlo a ver
pero mis hijos me estaban esperando aquí
camine siete días con sus noches por
cerros por montañas con hambre con frío
mis piezas deshechos sangrando y lo
único que me daba esperanza es ver al
cielo la luna era la que nos daba la luz
mi hija se llama luna cuando yo la veía
decía madre dios mío ayúdame yo tengo
que llegar con mis hijos después de esos
siete días de mucho dolor y sufrimiento
fuimos detenidos por la patrulla
fronteriza pero empecé a movilizar desde
adentro a través del teléfono organice a
mi comunidad en denver y en y en
washington móvil hice a nivel nacional
de esa manera pude salir pude salir del
centro de detención en el paso proceso y
center regresé a denver en mi primer
check in nuevamente me volvieron a
detener frente a mis hijos ver a mis
hijos llorar y gritar me llenó de más
rabia le dije al oficial que no iba a
ser fácil que él me sacara que cada
lágrima que mis hijos estaban llorando
yo se lo iba a cobrar que mi aspecto
decía una cosa pero lo que yo movilizaba
era otra y otra vez volvía a movilizar
desde dentro del centro de detención de
gio aquí en aurora móvil hice otra vez a
nivel nacional y pude salir pude salir
sabiendo que mi caso era más complicado
empecé a buscar opciones y recursos de
esa manera trabajé nueve meses creando y
fundando metro de inversión txuri
colisión que provee espacios seguros
dentro de iglesias a personas que tienen
sus casos de deportación en la parte
final para proveer ese espacio seguro
como desobediencia civil pacífica para
seguir peleando con el sistema
no lo utilice yo pero hasta 2017
me tocó con la administración trump
tener que refugiarme en santuario donde
estuve 82 86 días refugiada en santuario
peleando desde adentro porque estar
dentro de un santuario no significa que
es una prisión pero tampoco que no no
estás atada de manos para seguir
organizando organice y enfundado tres
organizaciones más que esa en chur y for
all que es una organización que provee
todo the new está ley alrededor de las
familias en procesos de deportación
fundéu a bolt y sites denver en 2018
viendo las injusticias que pasaban en la
frontera de la separación de niños de
sus padres encerrados en jaulas y decidí
que alguien tenía que hacer algo y esta
organización es para confrontar hacer
acciones directas en contra del sistema
y exponer públicamente todas las
injusticias y aberraciones que comete la
agencia dejo mis ryan secure y fundé la
organización de mujer que es de mujeres
que trabajan en limpieza de casas
cuidado de niños cuidado de adultos que
es un trabajo digno
pero que mucha mucha gente no reconoce
y s-video peleando mi caso pude salir
con un vil privado pero en este 2019 ya
quejo melián si quiere y no quiso
aprobar me este rumor tuve que volver a
refugiarme en santuario ahora estoy por
cumplir dos años pero eso no me ha
impedido seguir organizando en mi
comunidad seguir haciendo lo que creo
que sea necesario y aunque he pasado por
mucho dolor no sólo ha sido esa mi
batalla mi batalla a lo largo de estos
23 años ha sido también en contra del
privilegio blanco
también del racismo de la discriminación
porque lo sufrimos día a día la
comunidad inmigrante las comunidades y
las minorías de color no solo latinos
los asiáticos musulmanes y soy una de
las únicas hispanas aquí en colorado que
ha podido trabajar con todas las
comunidades que nos rodean musulmanes
asiáticos a froome
afrodescendientes mi propia comunidad la
gente nativo americana la comunidad
blanca porque me gusta crear
intersección de razas y comunidades para
crear justicia y dignidad por esa razón
yo digo que voy a seguir sembrando
voy a seguir sembrando rebeldía hasta
que cosecha libertad
que soy esa guerrera que nadie esperaba
pero que estoy aquí enfrente sigo
luchando sigo resistiendo no quiero que
me vean como víctima porque soy una
guerrera soy una guerrera que va a
seguir su lucha que no sé cuándo va a
terminar esto pero sé que todo tiene un
principio todo tiene un final y tengo
muchos proyectos en puerta todavía
porque todo lo que creo es para el
bienestar de mi comunidad y eso es ser
un residente no una víctima y esa soy yo
janet bisguerra residente
no
ah
y